se está politizando un asunto de
derechos aquí en este tema
bueno varias cosas con esto recordemos
que los Estados Unidos el tema del
aborto mencionaban antes que era un tema
constitucional lo que hizo la Corte
Suprema de Justicia es recordarle a este
país y el tema del aborto es considerado
una
función médica una actividad médica y
como tal los estados en el estado de en
Estados Unidos son los que deciden los
procedimientos médicos de la palabra los
procedimientos médicos en Estados Unidos
no son centralizados son estatales y en
ese aspecto creo que es la la narrativa
que han tratado de manejar los
demócratas en este ciclo electoral y
creo que no les ha funcionado
correctamente ahora precisamente qué tan
efectivo será este llamado a favor de
los demócratas por parte del presidente
wyden
bueno las encuestas lo han demostrado en
cuando la cuestión es que ellos
presentan encuestas donde dicen que la
gran mayoría apoya el tema de como ellos
le llaman derechos reproductivos la
realidad es que el tema del aborto sigue
siendo uno de los temas más Bajos en
todas las encuestas la prioridad ahorita
para las comunidades cualquiera que sea
tanto hispanas o afroamericanas es el
tema de la inflación el tema de la
economía el día a día como ese dólar que
antes compraba cierta cantidad de
productos hoy compra entre un 20 y un
30% menos precisamente por el tema de la
inflación ellos siguen apostando en este
tema pero definitivamente les va a
afectar en noviembre en las elecciones
que otros temas entonces podrían estar
moviendo a los votantes en estos
comicios aparte de los que usted ya
menciona
bueno es que el tema primordial aquí el
eje central de la elección presidencial
de la elección de medio término congreso
y cámara básicamente es el tema
económico aquí tenemos como señor dice
en inglés senior Cities gente mayor ya
adultos mayores que se están debatiendo
entre sí desayunan o cenan porque ya la
pensión no les alcanza y obviamente esas
personas el tema de los del aborto o de
los derechos reproductivos les importa
cero y creo que la inversión aquí debe
ser más tiene un grupo
de extrema izquierda dentro del partido
demócrata que sigue insistiendo en ese
en esa temática y la realidad es que van
a perder probablemente el congreso y el
senado en este noviembre y por lo menos
en el estado de la Florida vamos a ver
una solidificación del partido
republicano En este estado que antes era
considerado péndulo